James Sexton, one of the top divorce lawyers in New York City,
one of the most famous divorce lawyers here on TikTok,
has a video going outrageously viral,
almost 27 million views, where he starts out crying, saying,
she's gonna lose because she's poor.
She's gonna lose because she's poor,
because she doesn't have appropriate representation.
And he tells the story of how he's representing the father.
The mother is represented by a very young attorney,
one that's probably much more affordable or potentially pro Bono.
And because this young attorney doesn't know the proper terminology
to get something admitted,
because the court. Once you've spent some time in any court,
be it criminal, family,
anything, once you've spent any time understanding the law
and experiencing the law with your life,
you realize it is truly a game of semantics.
It's a game of technicalities.
It's not truly justice. It's not truly what's right and fair.
That is so idealistic and baby faced
to think that any court system goes that way.
So all his fucking tears are crocodile tears.
Did he profit from that win?
Yeah. At any point,
he could have stopped it and stopped the fucking game
and done something to change the system.
If he can see how broken it is,
and he has that much power and influence,
he could absolutely do something to make change.
Talking on TikTok just gets him notoriety,
just gets him more fame, just gets him more clients.
But he still playing The fucking game.
He still collecting the fucking checks,
he's still wearing the slick fucking suits
while single mothers are out here still fucking struggling
cause they can't pay for an attorney.
So Mister Fucking Sexton,
save your fucking crocodile tears and shove them up your.
Use them to wipe your own ass.
Because nobody gives a fuck that you're crying
while you're still collecting the fucking paychecks
and participating in the corruption of the family court.
No one should be put in the fucking position
that their families being ripped apart because of money
and you're fully fucking participating and benefiting from it.
Don't you dare fucking come on here and cry
and act like you're a fucking
so sorry or like a fucking victim.
Do something about it!